please welcome dr ann ramoyne
thank you so much oh we're not i was
gonna
bow be like i told everybody no
not even fist bumps the japanese had the
right idea
we don't know where that hand has been
that's no i don't mean you in particular
but
uh but you know you're okay right as far
as you know
but look i mean i said it in a minute
life will change
right and and it should first of all you
know what i never liked the handshake
anyway i don't think it
adds anything to anything right anybody
here you really care about touching here
you don't shake hands with
well you know there are lots of other
things you can do like i said you could
do the fist bump you could do the ebola
elbow
or you could just wave yes
exactly there are even studies now
are projects where they're trying to
have handshake-free zones in hospitals
just for the very same reason that we
don't want to be transmitting disease
and this was long before
right this new coronavirus i was told
that during the spanish flu in 1918
they stopped people well they tried to
stop they had a big campaign
against spitting people used to just
pack a loogie whenever
some still do but we don't as a as a
nation we generally don't expect a rate
correct
correct thank you so life is better post
epidemic
let's talk about the spanish flow
because it got my attention that they
said about two percent
of the world died in that one or who got
it right
and that seems to be the same number
they're saying now for this
i mean i always heard the spanish flu
was a rough one and
obviously if the numbers are the same
would you say this is a good comparison
well it's it's not time yet to compare
this to the flu
um and not even the spanish flu this is
a different kind of virus and we're
still learning a lot about it
i mean it's listen it's always scary
when you have a new pathogen jumping
from
animals into a human population starting
to spread and we just don't know
enough about this disease yet to really
make
uh strong comparisons because when we
talk about the spanish flu
we think you know we can we can talk
about it from a very long distance and
we know exactly how many cases there
were
we know now all about the epidemiology
of the
of the virus or of the disease but but
back then we
you know we we didn't and people were
just as scared then but if it's not a
flu
what is it so it's a coronavirus and a
coronavirus is different from an
influenza virus
coronaviruses are a large family of
viruses they also cause respiratory
infections but most of them are in
animals not in humans yes what is it
that humans will put anything in their
mouth
seriously i mean isn't this this started
when someone
ate a bat and i was thinking oh these
primitives and i remember ozzy osbourne
ate a bat before every show
well it actually isn't coming directly
from bats and
um same thing with sars or mers we think
that these
these viruses originate in bats and then
they jumped to another species
um with sars it was a civic cat with
mers it seemed to be a camel and in this
instance we're not sure yet but it seems
like it might be a pangolin and so it
comes
a pangolin which is a very small animal
that uh it's actually the most
uh trafficked animal in the world um
they're eating it they're eating it it
looks like an armadillo
they weren't eating the camel uh well
people were
were in a
no but but you know you bring up a
really good point these things often
happen
around wet markets and these are open
air markets where you have animals and
so you can imagine
walking into these markets that happen
everywhere in the world but in
particular in asia and africa
where you'll have you know you'll have
bats in a cage and then you'll have
pangolins in a cage above it
or uh you know civic cats and another
one and so you're having all of these
species all together
stressed and they're spreading disease
to each other and it's it's amazing
what the human body can ingest
and be okay right it's true i mean if
you ever
walked through you know markets just in
this country in
certain ethnic chinatown i've seen you
know [ __ ] on
sticks and animals hanging i mean it's
like
our our digestive system is almost too
strong
it can take so much that we'll just put
any piece of [ __ ] in our mouth
well you know i often when i teach a
class on epidemiology i often use the
example people because i work on ebola
it's another thing that i spend a lot of
time working on
and uh and that is also a disease that
crosses species from animals to humans
and people often talk about well people
eat bats and how could they eat bats and
i said well you know i mean culturally
people eat all sorts of things
um and and most of the time you're not
getting a disease spilling over i mean
people
eat meat but you know there's bad cow
disease if
yeah well yeah if you were the czar
the mike pence job would
crazy idea you with your degrees at a
title i can't even pronounce but okay
so would you stop planes from overseas
from certain countries from coming in
here
well i think you know these kinds of
draconian measures of
stopping travel they don't really work
at the end of the day
i mean listen the virus is already here
we already know that it's here and it's
already spreading
and the problem is when you really stop
travel and you have all these travel
bans people find ways in and then you
can't track them and then you don't know
what's happening and so
you know you have to be careful when you
really start putting these
these rules in place that are supposed
to stop people and then people who
really want to get in they're going to
find another way
um also it has so many problems with
trade
and and um you know all these other
diplomatic issues it it doesn't
necessarily make
that much of a difference so they're
better ways to be able to can you get it
twice
um that's a good question for this
particular coronavirus we don't know
there are other coronaviruses where
people have been able to be reinfected
but with this one we don't know yet but
don't you build
isn't it the whole point is that you get
something or you get a vaccine for it
then you have the immunity
why doesn't it work after one time well
you know that just certain diseases
um do not uh do not provide
immunity after the fact and which is why
you can keep getting them um
you know strep throat is another example
you could get that again right
so um right now we don't know it's very
possible that that
you could have immunity at least for a
period of time with this coronavirus but
but right now
like so many things about this virus but
you're very cheery about it i like that
no i mean no it's one reason i wanted to
have you on i
i learned this word once catastrophizing
when you make things that are not a
catastrophe into a catastrophe and that
isn't helpful and we don't really it's
not even appropriate right now is that
correct
you have to keep everything into
perspective here and and right now
we are learning what's happening we do
not have widespread
uh transmission here in the united
states we're still trying to figure out
that isn't that inevitable um you know
we're probably going to have
a fair amount of spread here in the
united states but we don't know how much
and we don't know where and it's not
going to happen overnight either
no but so what does happen if there are
two
i mean we only have a certain number of
hospital beds and we're not going to
build one in a week like the chinese
right right um not that that was really
a hospital
but i don't know if we could even put up
a room with beds we can't build home
for the housing for the homeless so i
don't have
well you know you're you're bringing up
i assume you're cheering that that's a
bad thing
no housing for the homeless great uh no
but you're bringing up
what what do we do if if all the beds
are filled
and there's x thousands more people
who need a respirator right well so so
first of all
what is going to happen is we're not
going to see like i said you're not
going to have this happen
all overnight right and we had other
bad flu seasons um you know we had the
we've already had a pandemic here we had
the h1n1 panned out
in 2009. so we have hospitals
prepared to a certain degree we know
what they need to do
they know what they need to do people
have been preparing for this you know
you can set
up makeshift hospitals as needed
but i think that this really brings up
the important point about pandemic
preparedness and how important
it is to be prepared and and the problem
has been is there haven't been there
hasn't been good
funding for this in a long time in fact
but no administration has been good at
funding pandemic preparedness
okay can i ask you it's a semi-political
question but it is a political show
um bernie sanders um
you know when people campaign for
president it's grueling
they always get sick as you might
imagine they're in planes all day with
that
crappy air recirculating and you're run
down
um plus he's 78 he just had a heart
attack
he showed this picture he's always in
crowds
touching a lot of people what's the
over under on him making it to election
i mean this does
[Laughter]
not
honestly seems like a perfect storm for
him not well you know um the the disease
is definitely
um people don't have as as um
successful
they don't have the successful outcomes
um uh in
in people that are older or who have
comorbidities if you love bernie
don't touch him right well you know i
respect you don't
touch bernie i would bet you that bernie
is doing what everybody else should be
doing right now which is washing your
hands
regularly i don't but not touching your
face i don't know if the crap i go into
the crowd and touch a million people
think
and survive this or should they say life
will change
and that's yes and that's okay and it is
yeah right yeah
but ultimately i would think
my theory you have to be
good about how you take care of yourself
your best line of defense
is it not your own immune system germs
pathogens are ubiquitous
you can't become howard hughes locked in
an airtight room pissing into jars
that's the only other alternative
right i mean people who put hand
sanitizer all over their hands all day
i've had more than one very smart doctor
tell me
that destroys the ph on the skin makes
it more permeable
you have to have a good immune system
stop eating sugar
wouldn't that be a great start well i
you know there are so many things that
you can be doing and sure sugar can
cause inflammation like so many other
things
isn't it the worst thing for your immune
system is sugar there are so many things
that are bad for immune
but wouldn't sugar be number one
sugar is in the in on the list of the
top things that you should probably
decrease but but you know they're
they're you know smoking is also bad and
and people should exercise more and they
should eat well in general and i think
that that's really
important and and so i agree with you
being healthy
and doing everything you can to make
sure you are healthy
including maybe eating less sugar would
be a good thing to do
no sugar but um finally
whatever it is they always end don't
they they do
they do whatever it's go it will end it
runs its course and then it ends
well i mean most of these viruses will
disappear although there are some
instances where they become
endemic let's end on that let's say they
always
all right thank you doctor i am bowing
to you
let's meet our family